وجودي معكم اليوم راح اشارك معاكم قصه
البدايات وانا سعيد جدا اني اكون ضمن احد
المتحدثين في محافظه الكرك واللي هي
بشبهها نفس محافظه المفرق اللي انا طلعت
منها
اول ما بلشت
درست في مدارس حكوميه وبتعرفوا المحافظات
بشكل عام ما بيكون فيها الفرص موجوده او
موجوده بس انت صعب جدا تحصل عليها
درست توجيهي وجبت من المتفوقين ودرست
هندسه الميكاترونكس لما دخلت على الجامعه
بشكل عام
مثل ما بنعرف انه الطب والهندسه احسن اشي
فانت بتفوت يا طب يا هندسه
دخلت هندسه وانا لسه مش عارف اذا التخصص
تبعي صح اذا المكان اللي انا رايح عليه
صحيح اذا الجامعه اللي انا اخترتها راح
تكون بالنسبه الي هي الخيار الصح او لا
اول سنه مثل ما بتعرفوا بيكون الطالب بشكل
عام لسه مش عارف بيتسائل
مع نفسه وبتساءل مع زملائه وبتساءل مع
الجامعه بلشت انخرط في مؤسسات مجتمع مدني
مثل ايزك واي تربل اي وتدكس وامريكا
الكورنر والاي تربل اي هذول المؤسسه نهر
الاردن كل مؤسسه من هدول المؤسسات
نمت فيني مهاره
كنت بحاجه لها كونه ما حصلت عليها بالمكان
اللي كنت موجود فيه القصه اللي راح
اشاركها معاكم يا جماعه ممكن تكون
شراره
لبدايه اي مشروع خاص لكل واحد فيكم احنا
بلشنا في مجال التجاره الالكترونيه بعام
2013 بعمل 2013 بلشت انا مثل ما حكيت لكم
انخرط في مؤسسات مجتمع مدني حتى اطور من
حالي ولكن وصلت لمرحله انه انا بدي مصدر
دخل ومصدر الدخل اللي انا كنت بدي اياه
يعني اقدر اني بشكل دائم اطلع فلوس بس
خلال فتره وجودي بالجامعه وكطالب بدرس
هندسه مش بالسهوله انك تطلع مصدر دخل لانه
راح يتعارض مع جامعتك ومع دراستك
اشتغلت العديد من الشغلات اشتغلت في
السيلز الماركتينج ريسبشنست مطاعم لبين ما
دورت على شغله اني ما اقدر ابيع وقتي
مقابل المال
لانه كل شغل كنت اشتغله لازم اداوم ثمان
ساعات واخذ فيكس
اللي هي حد ثابت للاجور سواء تعبت كتير
عندي امتحان ما عندي امتحان لازم يكون في
عندك حد انت تشتغله وبالتالي تحصل على اجر
هذا النظام بشكل عام كان مارقني انه انا
فعليا وقتي فل وعندي جامعه ومش قادر اطلع
من اكثر من 300 دينار اللي كنت بطلعهم
دورت على الانترنت بشكل عام على وسيله
اطلع منها فلوس ولقيت موضوع التجاره
الالكترونيه كان لساتها يعني في البدايات
في الاردن وكان راج طبعا في دول بره من
زمان
دورت على منتج ناجح وكان بالنسبه الي
المنتج الناجح بعد عده محاولات اللي هو
كفرات موبايل منتج ممكن يشتري صغير
والكبير كل حد بيشتري موبايل جديد ممكن
انه يشتري هذا المنتج وقدر اني اوصله
وابيعه اون لاين
كشخص
بدون اي معرفه بهذا المجال بلشت خلينا
نحكي اتعلم كل رياده اعمال بحاجه انه
يتمتع بالحد الادنى من المعرفه والخبرات
حتى يقدر يبحر في عالم البزنس او العالم
اللي هو بده يمشي فيه فمن الضروري جدا اني
اتعلم مهارات المحاسبه اتعلم الماركه
اتعلم الموردين اتعلم اللوجستيك اتعلم
الدليفري اتعلم التصميم اداره
الموظفين كيف تقدر تفتح شركه بعمر صغير
بتحكوا عن 22 سنه تقريبا كل المهارات هاي
مش موجوده عندي
ففعليا انت يا بتتعلم وبتتاخر اذا كانت
موجوده عندك او بكون في عندك مبلغ مالي
حتدفعه مقابل عدم معرفتك بهذا المجال
اللي صار يا جماعه انه فعليا كل واحد بده
يبلش اي خطوه بحياته بيروح بيسال اقرب
الناس عليه
بحكي له مرحبا انا بدي ابلش مشروع بقول لك
يا زلمه فكك من هالقصه مش حتزبط معك وكشخص
احنا كنا سكان محافظه المفرق فلما بتذكر
حكيت لشخص كثير قريب علي قلت له انا بدي
اعمل واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه وابيعهم
بعمان
لاقين شغل لحتى يشتروا من عندك كفرات
موبايل
الفكر لسه موجوده بس في عندي كان يعني
ايمان بانه انا مش حابيع المنتج انا حابيع
الديزاين اللي على المنتج مثل شباب
ممكن يكون سعره خمس دنانير بدون اللوجو بس
مع اللوجو صار سعره 25 دينار
بلشت واستوردت اول مره بحياتي بضاعه وكان
المبلغ اللي بلشت فيه دين 1500 دينار حق
الماكينه وست انواع كفرات
فعليا انا ما كنت يعني طموح كفايه كنت بس
بدي عشر دنانير دخل باليوم قلت اذا ببيع
كفر واحد
بطلع عشر دنانير كنت بدي ابيعه ب 13 دينار
3 دنانير كوست وعشر دنانير يضلوا ربح لالي
فقلت اذا ببيع واحد بطلع 300 دينار بالشهر
بدون ما اشتغل
وفعليا
انت بتكون ماشي بخطه الله بيعطيك اكتر
بكتير ما انت بتوقع بلشت المشروع وتدينت
المبلغ وجبت الماكينات وبعت اول اوردر
عملت اعلانات جدا بسيطه على فيسبوك وكان
لسه فيسبوك مش مستحود على انستغرام
اجاني اوردر من ولد صغير
طبع صوره الكلر اللي بحبه برشلونه وكتب
اسمه عليه بتذكره لهلا ورحت وصلت له اياه
لما رحت وصلت له اياه يعني هذا الموقف كل
ما بتذكره بقشعر بدني صراحه لانه هاي
النقطه او هذا اليوم وهاي الساعه هي اللي
تغيرت حياتي فيها
اعطاني الفلوس اعطاني فراته كانت زي ما
تقولوا فاتح الحصاله واعطاني اياهم فانا
صفيت السياره على جنب وصفنت
قلت العجله لفت شو يعني العجله لفت يعني
انا فكرت بفكره
واستوردت المنتج وعملت بيج وعملت اعلان
على المنتج ولقيت كاستمر اشترى مني ودخلت
علي فلوس
لما دخلت الفلوس كنت واثق تماما انه حياته
حتتغير بهذا اليوم اذا نجح المشروع لانه
منتج واحد كفيل بتغيير حياه اي شخص
اليوم احنا في مجال التجاره والتسويق
الالكتروني بحاجه تعرف ثلاث شغلات حتى
تقدر تنجح بهذا المجال بدك برودكت
منتج ناجح
وبدك
محتوى ناجح اللي هو كونتنت
فيديو لحتى تعرض المنتج وبدك
اودينس فاذا وصلت بين هدول الثلاث باذن
الله نسبه نجاحك بتكون جدا عاليه
فبفضل الله والتوفيق طبعا اولا
قدرت اني اعمل الكاشف له باول لوب اللي هي
العجله الماليه لفت
بعد اول اسبوع
طلعت 1500 دينار
طبعا فعليا الواحد ما بيكون مخطط انه بدك
تطلع ارقام او تبيع اوردرات انا كنت مخطط
اني ابيع واحد باليوم الله رزقني عشره فمن
واحد راتبه بالشهر 300 دينار لواحد بيعمل
باليوم 150 دينار
90% منهم مربح
بعد اسبوع او عشر ايام حكيت مع الشخص اللي
اعطاني الفلوس قلت له مرحبا كيف الحال انا
بدي اشوفك قال لي ايش فيه قلت بدك فلوس
زياده قلت له بس اشوفك بنحكي رحت لعنده
قلت له هاي المبلغ
قال لي بالحرام باخذه قلت له ابن الحلال
ليه قال لي انا اعطيتك اياه تبلش المشروع
قلت له انا بلشت
وبعت وهذا المربح قال لي اقعد شو بتشتغل
شغلني معك
وفعليا هو راح فتح بيج ببيع امور طبعا هذا
الحكي يا جماعه بحكي 2013
وانا مبسوط جدا اني بحكي لطلاب يعني من
جيلي لما بلشت فانت فعليا كل واحد فيكم
عنده الفرصه انه ينجح او يبيع منتج او
يبيع خدمه لحتى يغير او يحقق هدف معين
بعد اول ست اشهر صرنا تيم مكون او شركه
مكونه من 11 شخص
صرنا نبيع بكل الاردن
وبعد فتره بسيطه ثمان اشهر صرنا نستهدف في
السوق السعودي
العمليه كبرت وبدل المنتج صار عنا 200
منتج بدل الدليفري صار عنا خمسه دليفري
وصلنا متعاقدين مع شركه ارامكس وفي سنه من
السنوات او شهر من الاشهر كنا احنا اكثر
شخص او اكثر شركه بتوزع اوردرات
بالاردن واخذنا زي ما تقولوا وسام من شركه
ارامكس انه احنا اكثر شركه بعثت اوردرات
في الاردن بهذا الشهر
فعليله يا جماعه لما كنت بالجامعه
على السنه الثانيه والثالثه والرابعه ما
كنتش كفايه مع التخصص انا درست هندسه
كهرباء وميكانيك بس عقلي او ميولي كامل
رايح نحو البزنس
فما كنتش متاكد انه انا بالجامعه عم بدرس
مواد ممكن مش شايف انه انا فيها وبالتالي
تحصيل الدراسه ما كان عالي بس كنت واثق
تماما انه اذا بغير المكان تبعي ادرس بزنس
مثلا حكون ادائي جدا افضل بعد فتره من
السنوات وانا بالجامعه صار عندي بزنس
وبفضل الله يعني بعنا اوردرات جدا كبيره
وحققنا ارقام بفضل الله رهيبه قلت اذا
منتج واحد او بيج واحده بتحقق لي هذا
الربح احنا يوميا كنا نعمل
من 500 ل 1000 دينار مبيعات
تقريبا من 15 لعشرين الف دينار بالشهر
حملت حالي ورحت على الصين
رحت الصين حتى اجيب منتجات اكتر
لقله الخبره
دفعت تقريبا مبلغ 40 الف دولار خساره
المبلغ اللي دفعته لو ترجع فيه الزمن هلا
وتحكي لي برجع لك اياه اقول لك ما بدي
لانه فعليا انت بتحصل على الخبره من كيسك
انت بتجرب وبتتعلم وبتروح وبتسافر وبتلتقي
مع اشخاص وبتغلط وبالتالي تتعلم مش
بالضروري تغلط عشان تتعلم بس هذا الطريق
اللي كان قدامي
لما استوردت بضاعه ورجعت على الاردن طلعت
البضاعه غير مطابقه وبتعرفوا انه لما
تستورد لاول مره وخصوصا من الصين بتواجه
مشاكل غير مطابق المواصفات المقاييس او
السنين نفسهم كان في عندهم اشكاليه
بالاوردرات رجعت مره تانيه وحبيت اني احل
هاي المشكله لحتى
اساعد كل شخص بده يشتري منتجات اكون انا
حكيت للشباب انه انا بدي افتح مكتب لوجستك
وشحن وفعلا حكوا لي اذا بدك تفتح مكتب
لوجستك وشحن لازم تتعلم اللغه الصينيه
سجلت باقرب جامعه لغه صينيه لمده سنه ونص
ودرست اللغه الصينيه قراءه وكتابه وفتحت
المكتب
لاحظوا يا جماعه
مجال نجاحك او الابواب اللي عم تنفتح لك
مش بالضروره تنجح بالمكان اللي انت فيه
اليوم
انتم صح سك الكرك بس ما حدا حتى ما عليك
انك تبيع منتجاتك بالكرك وتقدر تفتح حله
بالكرك وتبيع بعمان وكل راس مالها تعمل مع
شركه توصيل
انت صح عم تدرس هندسه او صح عم تدرس طب بس
مش بالضروره انك تحكم على حالك انه انت
فقط بهذا المجال
اذا حاسس حالك مش بمكانك الصحيح لاقي شغفك
لانه فعليا حتحس حالك ما عم تشتغل لما
تروح على الشغل
فتحت المكتب وبعديها فتحنا اكاديميه
بمجمع الحسين الاعمال وبندرب بمجال
التجاره والتسويق الالكتروني
المجال اللي بلشنا فيه يا جماعه لقينا انه
احنا في عندنا عصاره خبره من اكثر من سوق
ومن اكثر من بلد وزرت عده مصانع وفتحت عده
خلينا نحكي متاجر الكترونيه لبيع وشراء
المنتجات وبفضل الله جزء كبير منها لقى
نجاح جدا ممتاز
احنا اليوم صرنا مدربين ما يقارب الف طالب
وطالبه بمجال التجاره والتسويق الالكتروني
اخر سنتين
الطلاب موجودين في الاردن 80% منهم
بالاردن والعشرين بالميه من كل دول العالم
لانه في عنا اون لاين وفي عنا تعليم وجاهي
اللي بدي اوصلكم اياه يا جماعه
انه بالوقت الحالي ما حد فينا بيعرف شو
بده يصير بعد خمس سنين
والسوق اليوم بحتم عليكم تتعلموا مهارات
اكثر ما تتعلموا تخصص التخصص بساعدك يفتح
لك ابواب معينه بس تطلع من هذا الباب او
من هاي الجامعه اذا انت مش تعبان لحالك
كفايه السوق
مش راح ينصفك
مش راح يرحمك الناس اللي موجوده خارج
الجامعه في عندك تجار حيتان في حال دخلت
عالم التجاره والبزنس وفي عندك
اشخاص تعبوا اكثر منك وبالتالي حققوا
مستوى معارف اعلى منك فاستعد قد ما تقدر
ويوم الناس تاتيك الفرصه
تضلك انت الليدر وتبحر بالمركب اللي انت
ماشي فيه بحاجه تتمتع بعده مهارات
احنا ممكن قبل 20 سنه او 30 سنه
شخص بحكي لغه انجليزيه يكون هو المرجع
بالقريه او بالمحافظه او بالمكان اليوم
شخص معه ثلاث شهادات او اربع شهادات
ومسافر 30 دوله وبحكوا ثلاث لغات وبعمل
برمجه وعنده يوتيوب تشانيل وعنده نص مليون
متابع ويا دوب ضابط معه الامور
فبحاجه تتمتعوا وتتسلحوا بالعلم قد ما
تقدروا ونصيحتي دائما اللي بعطيها للشباب
اللي بندربهم
مسؤوليتك اليوم يا جماعه الجامعه ما كان
حتى تقدم لك الاشي اللي انت بتحتاجه
لتتعلم
حبيت تتعلم وتتعب على حالك امورك تمام ما
حبيت انت بتضر حالك
رحله التعلم دائما
وابدا يجب ان تبقى مستمره حتى تقدر تتطور
كثير من الاشخاص بيطلبوا مثال بشركه نوكيا
انه ما قدرت تواكب السوق علما انها كانت
في اوج المجال تبعها
وبعد فتره اليوم شركه نوكيا ملهاش مكان
بين التوب 10 الالكترونكس بالعالم
تطورك المستمر
باي مجال سواء بتدرس طب او هندسه
او محاسبه الكتب اللي عم تقراها هلا اذا
مش عم بتكون
تسقطها على ارض الواقع وعم بتجيب نتيجه ما
بزبط انت تدرس
او تدرس كتب محاسبه وصار في عندك برامج
لسه مش عارف تشتغل عليها
المهندس المعماري ما بزبط بعده يرسم بايده
لازم يتعلم كيف يشتغل على برامج معينه حتى
يقدر ينتج الشغل بكفاءه اعلى وبالتالي
قيمه
المضاف القيمه المضافه لكل شخص فينا اللي
بيعطيها للشركه او له او للمؤسسه اللي راح
يشتغل فيها هي اللي راح ترجع عليه
في اشخاص بالاردن
راتبهم عشره الاف دينار اردني وعشرين الف
وفي ناس ب 30 الف
البلد دائما فيها شغل وباقصى الظروف الشغل
موجود
سوريا بالحرب بكون في شغل مخيم الزعتري
بالحرب حركه الدول المالي باليوم اكثر من
مليون دينار اردني
بالحرب
وبالتالي ما بدك تكون الشخص اللي عم بشكي
بشكل مستمر
ويلوم اشخاص ثانيين بتلوم الحكومه بتلوم
الظروف بتلوم الجامعه بتلوم حالك بتلوم
اهلك بتلوم الكرك
انت المسؤول بمجرد ما تمسك زمام الامور
وتاخذ مسؤوليه الاشي اللي انت عم تعمله
راح تقدر توصل لمرحله ولهدف انت راسمه
لما برجع على ايام الجامعه ما كنتش شايف
حالي بالمره اني راح اوصل لمكان اللي انا
موجود فيه اليوم وممكن انا بعتبر حالي لسه
ما وصلت واحد منكم عم يشارك تجربته بمجال
معين
بس فعليا دائما حاول تعمل
الخطوه اللي بين ايديك هلا انت وين كل
واحد فينا يا جماعه عنده مسؤوليات وعارف
شو عليك وشو الك وعارف نقاط قوتك وعارف
نقاط ضعفك
انت الشخص اللي راح تكون قادر تعرف اذا
انت لما تروح على مقابله عمل وما لقيت شغل
تسال حالك ليش ما وظفوني اسال حالك انت
بتوظف حالك عند حالك
والله انا عندي مشكله باللغه الانجليزيه
وعندي مشكله بالوورد وما بعرف اعمل
اعلانات وعندي مشكله بالكومينيكيشن مش
مشكله
طورهم اشتغل عليهم اليوم العلم موجود اوبن
سورس
تقدر تصير مبرمج بلغه البايثون عن طريق
يوتيوب
تقدر تطور مهاراتك والوقت اللي عم تقضيه
اليوم
هو اللي راح يحدد مين انت بعد خمس سنوات
مش الفجن تبعك اليوم تبع خمس سنوات انت شو
بدك تصير حتصير
24 ساعه الي عم تقضيها بشكل يومي
والامور اللي عم تعملها هي اللي راح توصلك
للمكان اللي انت بدك اياه
وعشان الوقت
بختم
بمقوله يعني معلقها عندي من ايام التوجيهي
اذا عم تعمل اقصى جهدك لانجاز مهمه معينه
وهذا الحكي مش عم بجيب لك نتيجه اعمل اكثر
يعطيكم الف عافيه شكرا لكم